- All right, so are y'all
ready for some positivity?
(Skype ringtone)
(crowd cheering and clapping)
What?
Oh my gosh, what's up, DJ Khaled?
- Yo Kelly, that's you?
- Yes, what's up, are you my surprise?
- What, you do, it looks like
you're doing a show or something,
I was supposed to be
getting my poker game on
with Josh Groban, and
you know, get to the bag.
What, what's going on?
- Wait, what?
No, this is, no, this is,
you've just Zoomed my show.
This is the Kelly Clarkson Show, you know?
This is my show, yeah.
- Oh no, you know what?
You know I've got love for you,
but I think I'm on the wrong Zoom!
- Oh, okay, well, you should
drop by for music week,
but that's fine, that's totally cool.
I wasn't in invited to a poker
game, that's totally fine.
(audience laughing)
But while you're here,
like I'm just saying,
could you maybe give us a major key
for season two inspiration?
I mean, you're here, we're here, why not?
(audience applauding)
- Oh, of course, Kelly, you
know I got love for you.
The major key is to make sure
they watch The Kelly Clarkson Show
because it's gonna put
a smile on your face.
(shouts)
And that's a major key alert.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Yes, I love that major key!
- That's a major key alert.
- DJ Khaled, everybody,
I'll get you the right number
for Josh Groban, it's fine.
- Yeah, and finish your show,
but I love you, all right?
- All right, bye, DJ Khaled!
My kids love lemonade,
that's their favorite thing is lemonade.
- Oh, perfect!
- I can't give it to 'em too much,
but I have this big frickin'
tree at the new house we're in.
- [John] You have a lemon tree?
- Dude-
(Skype ringtone)
What in the?
(jazzy clarinet melody)
Is that my surprise?
- It's Kenny G, oh!
- Kenny G!
(audience applauding and cheering)
Oh my, hello!
- We can't hear you!
- You can't hear me?
- Now we can.
- Oh, I can hear you, are you my surprise?
- No, I mean, why am I seeing you guys?
I'm supposed to be hooking
into Josh Groban's poker party.
Are you part of the party?
- Wait, what?
(audience laughing)
Wait, no, no, but I like poker.
- Hey, I'm sorry to see
that you're not going
because I would have really enjoyed
taking some of that sexiest
man alive money off of John.
(audience laughing and applauding)
- All right.
- I think it's funny you
thought I got money for that.
(audience laughing and applauding)
- Oh my gosh, well, okay,
well, you've gotta come
on the show at some point.
I'm sorry, I'll get you
the right number, okay?
- Okay, I'd sure like to do that.
So first of all, good
luck for the next season.
- Oh, thank you.
- And John, just do a favor.
Don't get him on the saxiest
man alive competition, okay?
- Oh!
- That's 'cause it's
taken, John, it's taken.
- [John] I get it!
- Get it, Kenny G!
Oh my gosh, he's awesome!
- He got jokes, too!
- Have fun at your poker game.
We didn't get invited to
a poker game, whatever.
But first, everyone knows John's wife,
Chrissy Teigen, is the cook in the family,
and she's got books, people, and-
(Skype ringtone)
Oh my gosh, Nellie, are you my surprise?
- Hey, Kelly!
- It's Nellie!
- Are you my surprise, Nellie?
(audience claps and cheers)
I love you!
- Oh wow, this is dope, I didn't know
you guys were playing
in the poker game today!
- Oh my God, you've gotta be kidding me!
- This poker game.
- First of all, I'm really
upset that we weren't invited,
and secondly, it's the wrong number!
(audience laughing)
- Oh, do you have Josh's number?
I hate to ask you, but-
- Okay, great, yeah, no,
I mean, I wasn't invited,
but I'll get you the
number, it's totally cool,
I'm not offended.
Uh-huh, Nellie, everybody!
(audience cheering and applauding)
- [Nellie] No problem, appreciate it!
- You've gotta tell Josh, we love you!
- Hey John!
- Peace, Nellie!
- I'll tell Josh you said hi, John!
- Welcome back, everybody.
It's a music week and what
better way to kick it off
than with a perf-
(Skype ringtone)
Huh?
(audience claps and cheers)
Oh, Josh Groban!
Are, you know what, Josh Groban?
You're not my surprise!
- Kelly?
- You have a fricking poker game going on!
- Can you hear me?
I know, listen, Kelly, I called,
I just called in to apologize
mainly because I gave all
my friends your Zoom room
instead of my Zoom room by accident,
and I apologize for the
inconvenience and it will not,
it will not happen again.
But I just wanted to call
in and not only say sorry,
but to say that, you
know, I think it's great
you're doing music week because
music is helping all of us
get through these crazy, crazy times.
And so, thank you for that.
And again, I'm very, very sorry.
- Yeah, no, that's real sweet and all.
When were you gonna say sorry
for not inviting me to your poker game?
Just curious, just waiting
for that one, yeah.
Is it just all full of men, no?
- You should check your junk folder.
I think it's probably in there, Kelly.
- You're so full of it, Groban!
No, I'm just kidding, I love you so much.
I gave the right number to
everyone, don't worry about it.
It is great to see you.
You've gotta come back
soon, we love you here.
- I would love that Kelly,
and you are always welcome
to any virtual poker game anytime.
you seem a little busy right now though,
but love to you and love
to everybody, stay safe.
- I will make time for poker
time with Groban, but whatever.
Bye, Josh! (laughing)
(audience cheering and applauding)
I love Groban, although I kind
of had to self invite myself,
it's fine.
(audience laughing)
It's not the first time, people.